I couldn't think of a fun opening line
so let's just get to it Star Wars rogue
one I don't know if this is gonna be the
standard set up from here on you're
probably not gonna see too much the
green screen in the near future a long
story but in any case I'm now seeing
rogue one so what do we think pretty
good pretty good pretty solid I'm gonna
try and avoid getting too spoilery with
this but you know it's good and it's fun
and there's a lot to like about it this
effectively in a nutshell if I'm really
breaking it down this is what I want out
of these sort of Star Wars story these
sort of cycles these not the main number
of series things which is something that
is set in the Star Wars universe but is
a different flavor and a different take
on it it does not have the same tone
that these standard Star Wars movies
have but it still feels Star Wars is
still steeped in that world in that tech
in that conflict and this is that this
is a war story set in the Star Wars
universe and it is the kind of war story
that we haven't gotten up to this point
because we generally gotten the big
overarching things you know we're
dealing with the rebel fleet we're
dealing with the generals we're dealing
with the sort of top-down look this is
on the ground this is the dirty fighting
and in war sometimes your hands get
pretty darn dirty and sometimes you have
stuff carried out by people that the
history books they're not gonna mention
them
that's rogue one and so you've got this
ragtag team of rebels that are sort of
trying to get information about this new
weapon which of course we all know is
the Death Star the cast is good now the
highlight by far is the new droid it's
k2 performed by Alan Tudyk he is just
awesome and funny really really funny in
the best sort of sarcastic literalized
way that droids tend to be funny Donnie
Yen who was the blind sort of monkish
guy he worked really well for me too I
was expecting to be annoyed by him
because like I didn't want to feel like
like
and the force we're taking over
something that was gonna be at least I
hoped I'm more grounded military story
but you know what it just he just felt
like a guy with faith as opposed to
being a Jedi so that worked first
Whittaker saw Guerrero was an
interesting wrinkle because he sort of
makes you realize that the Rebel
Alliance is what it sounds like it is an
alliance of these different factions
that they're not always completely
unified though because he's sort of he's
referred to as an extremist by Mon
Mothma so like you've got elements
within even those who are fighting the
Empire that they don't all get along and
that makes sense that's a cool wrinkle
and we get to see lots of stuff that
that really if you wanted before you had
to read extended universe stuff which
was never really my bag but we get to
see what it's like to live under the
heel of the Empire we've never really
gotten that before the action is good
it's hard-hitting it's a it's a well
paced movie the villains pretty good
commander chronic is I feel like he is
what they wanted
general Hux in the force awakens to be
now I actually kind of like general Hux
I didn't everyone else seems to hate him
he works for me but this guy works
better and he's kind of cut from the
same mold in that he is he's a high
ranking military official but he's he's
gunning for favoritism by the people who
are above him and so then they've got
that going I like said it's like general
Hux but working better now I'm not gonna
put this in your ranked relative to all
the other Star Wars movies it's better
than the prequels absolutely no doubt
I'm not sure I would rank it above any
of the other main series even the force
awakens although I think it's gonna come
down to personal taste it's not perfect
though jyn erso who's kind of them it
really isn't ensemble piece but she's
fine she's functional but I do I never
quite completely bought into her
emotional hook and she's supposed to be
carrying a lot of the emotional weight
of the movie and that part of it I it's
not that I didn't have any emotional
investment but my emotional investment
had to do with my existing emotional
investment in Star Wars in you know
these this sort of world in this
struggle that I already
kind of cared about and her specifically
she never quite hooked me I think to the
extent that she was supposed to but this
is a good time it's Star Wars
it looks like Star Wars but it feels
like a different take on it that this is
what I wanted out of this movie so I
consider it to be a really good time
and if you know Star Wars especially
that first movie front to back there are
so many Easter eggs here for you it's
crazy and every single one of them put a
smile on my face even though you know
they weren't really necessary but I
still liked them for being there so
that's my thoughts on Star Wars rogue
one I'm taking part in a podcast that's
probably going to go into a bit more
detail might be more spoilery than this
I don't know we're recording in a few
minutes but that'll be on Ryan dailies
give me those Star Wars podcast which I
will provide a link to down in the
description as soon as it's up I might
have this video up before the podcast
goes up and I'll add it later whatever
but have you seen rope 1 if you have
what you think about it whatever you
thought drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at council of geeks follow the
counsel of geeks podcasts available on
iTunes and stitcher Pat until next time
this council is adjourned